c'est à pied qu'il doive faire les
derniers 800 mètres qui les séparent de
l'ukraine celle toujours sous le
contrôle du gouvernement il habite
lougansk kirovski et al chaïef sq des
villes de la république autoproclamée de
lougansk ils sont venus ici pour y
rester quelques heures avant que la
russie ne reconnaissent la république
officiellement et ordonne le déploiement
de troupes via
nous sommes des patriotes alors nous
venons en ukraine didine à marina elle
s'inquiète pour son frère resté derrière
il sera forcé à se battre pour les
rebelles indépendantistes
elle en est convaincu
il envoie des lettres 12 l'a pas reçu
encore mais de toute façon ils les
prennent dans la rue dit elle tous les
hommes plus de voix aux tirs tous sauf
les vieux ils peuvent encore quitté sans
problème nous distille mais pas question
pour ce couple de partir vers la russie
dans les convois d'évacuation
ils fabriquent une ambiance de peur pour
forcer les gens partir en russie dit
guennadi mais c'est pour les images pour
faire un film
le film le calcul il sort ça se mettre à
l'abri d'une possible intensification
des combats tout en sachant très bien
que de ce côté-ci du point de passage la
situation sécuritaire n'est guère mieux
natalia ray puis passé quand les vitres
de sa maison ont été soufflées par un
mortier le toit endommagé
il est tombé dans son jardin
heureusement il était chez sa mère juste
à côté jules base d'arôme je suis en vie
et en santé mais c'est une honte une
honte dit elle
quand ça va finir ça fait déjà tant
d'années depuis 2014 nous sommes des
êtres vivants mais combien de temps à
nous user les nerfs avec ses tirs avec
cette guerre de mantel nous sommes
prisonniers de cette situation qui se
tourner pour chelsea
ses voisins sont tous venus lui prêter
main forte pour ne pas qu'elles dorment
sous la pluie ou frigorifiés par les
bourrasques de vent
encore beaucoup d'ukrainiens habite à
quelques dizaines de mètres des
positions de l'armée ukrainienne de plus
en plus pris pour cible
l'ukraine n'a pas ordonné l'évacuation
de la population
c'est le cas ici tout près de ce poste
d'observation de l'armée
ils restent ici de plein gré nous dix
commandants et nous restons parce que
c'est notre devoir de plein gré pour
certains peut-être mais il ya une sorte
de fatalité imposé dans la vie des
habitants des villes qui longe la ligne
de front
la ville de chastes ya été réveillée au
son d'une pluie de tirs de mortier
d'artillerie dès 6h ce matin en fin de
journée il n'y avait toujours pas de
signe d'accalmie
le bruit sourd des détonations étaient
constants
trois obus sont tombés devant la
station-service où travaille ou cela
mais il ne va nulle part pourquoi
bordeaux
bruges et doit rester ici dit il on ne
peut pas laisser la station peut-être
que notre patron nous dira autrement
mais en attendant on reste là et on a
peur
voilà ce que l'on sent ce que l'on
entend ou là des bruits de la guerre la
peur la lassitude l'impuissance ici
marie ève bédard radio-canada stanic à
lougansk